[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est vraiment la mine truc trava
rentre d pas pas prendre
parkingessusraent dedans ded ded
voilàil voilà comme ça voil tuux traeur
de gauche à GAE gauche pe garder voil
mais voil voil
voil la matière garde la matière à ta
gauche là voilà parce que voilà
[Applaudissements]
ok voilà on tourne comme ça doucement
voilàas tout le
bordel la matière dans dans la terre
vachement travaillé tu vois la matière
qui est vachement travaillé c'est
[Applaudissements]
joli
tu s vachement la mine là quand même ou
la lumière ça y est elle est top là
c'est
bonas vraiment t les Mar les marques des
camions c'est
génial prend bien je regarde ça va
donner de Lig a du
mouvement slow slow
[Musique]
tu ça va être très joli à gauche là
voilà tu une super lumière slow
slow tous les camions qui
[Musique]
attendent bien soisedans voilà dedans
voilà la lumière est superbe plus ver
voil de de camions voilà voilà c'est
vachement beau
[Musique]
ça
un peu plus vers la droite voilà par
contre la grue elle est pas en acttivité
je crois qu'elle est en train de refuler
là
la grue qui est la grue qui est là
derrière elle charge en tout cas doncis
celle qui là c'est bien voilà doucement
pourquoi tu zoomes si vite on pour s'en
servir de Cees trucs
là là il est bien quand tu as les deux
camions
là c'est es trop serré desserre-toi en
vitesse s'il te plaît desserre-toi
desserre-toi voilà prends les deux
camions ensemble voilà top top top top
vas-y rentre dedans maintenant rentre
dedans voilà moi trop tard VO ouais oua
voilà comme ça t
ouais tant pis on va doucement comme ça
désolé désolé hop on continue comme ça
moi j'avais un super plan mais c'est vra
qu'on a tourné
c'estû désolé je t fa faire une
connerie va passer verticale
vertical
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
OK et on va s'en aller donc il va le on
va aller vers le vers les le vers le
Goudon là-bas là où y avait tout à
l'heure le mec
était
bien un truc avec les traces de camion
allerin de
truc juste l'entr comme ça a les
[Applaudissements]
Maram
[Musique]
qui
[Applaudissements]
ah
allez c'est bon pour toi non
attends bon je coupe ou pas tu vois le
bulldoer qui travaille là tu vois le mec
qui travaille le bulldozer non le tant
qu'il est à gauche regarde tuas un PLL
qui travaille dedans qui pousse la terre
pe pas tout seul B prends les
traces qu'il a sur le côté à droite il a
plein de trac tu vois on va les voir
quand on va tourner voilà prends le bien
prend le bien voilà comme ça
voilà voilà voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà vachement les marques toutes les
marques des trucs tu vois
[Applaudissements]
vachement
audessus tuas plein de marqu quand tu
vas devant lui devant lui tu as plein de
gros trous de chez toi là tu vas un peu
devant
lui devant le devant lui tu vas voir
voil un trou plein de
[Applaudissements]
trucs pas trop trop ser c'est vachement
beau
tu vas devant devant là on tourne on
tourne dessus ouais mais qu'estce
tu veux que je fasse d'autre dis pas
autre
chose je fais ça pour toi moi
là
bon bon tu en as assez là non ouais
ouais c'est bon tu vois c'est devant lui
tu vois espèce de bordel c'est ça que je
voulaux dire tu vois devant
le moi si je le cadre tu vois je cadre
en pasimage comme on l'a là
VO voil voilà c'est ça voilàas tous les
trous voilà c'est vachement beau ça tu
vois voilà même comme ça c'est beau
regarde j'adore moi ça voilà ton comme
ça c'est super pour parce que j'ai
l'amorce j'aiutre chose
en C tu gardes voil tu gardes la droite
tu gardes à droite bordel tu vois voilà
ça que j'aime moi voilà voilà doucement
voil voil bien à droite tout
ça va aller un peu plus loin pour
[Musique]
bordel partir de là quit comme
çae
çaz comme ça comme
ça
qui contre jour vachement beau
voilà
[Applaudissements]
ça composer en
[Musique]
rouant second